hello rejects I'm Greg with me it's the
lovely
Shelly Nanaia hmm Selena is on Instagram
and snapchat and like coach chill light
like light yeah light like lightbulb
yes coach as a coach Carter chill as in
I like to roll a blunt and chill
[ __ ] and snapchat and she okay
yeah let's keep it like that
anyway when I first met Lina she used to
be into this show called Naruto raka
raka is one of my favorite YouTube
channels of all time raka raka let me
tell you who they are really fast I
don't think you've seen it or videos
most of the videos kind of go down like
this they're just these dudes I think
they're Australian or New Zealand I
constantly forget no matter funny but
they're very violent this might not be
so violent when they do specific oh ma
jizz this is called the Naruto show I
have never seen the root oh okay so I'm
doing this strictly to show you can't
this is tailor-made for someone who used
to watch the show made for me I don't
know if this is gonna be violent I have
no I mean ready for anything that's
called any stations let's do this
alright let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa this gotta make me want to watch
the show
very cool guys Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
super ah egg and they just blow their
way really yeah not me but like
[Music]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] Wow awesome
[Music]
[Music]
that's pretty cool that is so awesome
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
so cool
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
in every movie oh wow
raka raka awesome who are you people
you guys are amazing yeah I met these
guys about a year and a half ago maybe a
little longer than that ah VidCon you
know at VidCon is new it's a convention
for for like internet people yeah like
if you want to see your prettiest Viner
or snapchatter mmm that's a place pretty
boy dude or some debugger Olli yeah okay
that's where you go Network what's up
it's just not it's not for me number you
I can't know because that's where like a
lot of like fake internet people look
Alex can't stand these guys not gonna
loose anyone specifically but you can
just feel it when you're like
interacting with them or seeing them
interact with people it's a place for
like 13 year old girls and boys to go
you know what do like the fans go doing
meet yeah fans for fans to go to
obviously have these people so it's cool
for them okay it's not for me not
actually the booths but every year I get
an invite to go well that makes you guys
I mean these cool people it's me it's
I'm like that cool actor who doesn't
attend the Oscars that's it that's
that's what idea I'd like I just done a
10-bit come anyway
bake on one of the cool parts of VidCon
was I got to meet these guys that is the
that is a very clear these guys are
awesome and it was just busy told the
story it started off with just two dudes
these my twin brothers homie we yeah the
main guys playing the root oh yeah yes
it's one brother okay and they would
just put together these like crazy
sketches were like no budget and then
lately they just been getting bigger and
bigger and I heard they have a film and
worse possibly with Universal Studios
but they just started from nothing and
they grow into this you know like it's
incredible it's absolutely inspiring
that is Millions
that was like almost like movie status
the like it's like in this beautiful
area where yeah you could tell they put
so much work into it
yeah like the whole plot of it was just
hilarious how was it for you as a fan of
Naruto I absolutely loved it it was fun
because I haven't seen it number two in
a really long time so just like to be in
that world again was amazing you should
know like everything that was going on
there oh yeah like it's all coming yeah
no but my favorite part was definitely
when he was eating the ramen noodle in
the middle of the fight because he loves
his [ __ ] Namit ramen noodle it looks
so good I did actually have a noodle
sounds so silly shy I haven't seen a
root oh but just on a technical scale of
like looking at the effects and the
scope and like the the sequence of them
like flying through the air and fighting
and like is clearly not like
computer-generated it was wire effects
Samsonite like a helicopter or something
and then like when they're fighting on
the water line I was like whoa this is
crazy
yeah to see how far these guys have come
and just from having fun and wanting to
make fun and a root of it because the
thing that they tend to do is like they
want to make they make fun and stuff but
they also make it kind of cool yeah I
mean yeah that's some like like parkour
stuff like yeah that's awesome that's
takes a lot of work to frickin get on
that level of just like doing all those
stunts and everything as well one of my
goals for next year is to make more
sketches and short films that would be
awesome and I'd love to be a part of
that please that'd be great
I want to do more fight scenes too I've
done fights I haven't done like one
fighting like a couple years ago on this
channel that's cool I've seen one of
them you had that was the only one yeah
well I was really fun to watch yeah
they'll watch that video good little
promo for myself brain three egg hunter
that's what it's called anyway guys
please subscribe to rack a rakha please
do yourself for favors watch more other
videos because a lot of their videos
tend to be grotesquely violent so they
might not all be for you if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe today
please do that thank you
selena is light coach chill motherfuckas
at instagram no no like coach chill
Instagram and snap
chat she is the host coordinator of an
event called color my energy where if
she coordinates with me I might be able
to get a slot of color my energy coming
up to him and then I could tell you guys
about it so if you live in LA or in
California just want to drive over and
watch come on yeah with you guys nice I
could color my energy I don't go all the
time but when I go I'm there like all
day
I don't like wait I don't leave early
you got to do it the right yeah yeah I
stand I stay the whole I stay the whole
time yeah promotion complete third
Wednesday of every month
yeah completed